well good evening welcome to a special
edition of Piers Morgan uncensored last
time my guest was here a few weeks ago I
left wanting a lot more I thought why
aren't we doing a whole hour with this
guy so I asked him he couldn't
understand why we went either so he
agreed and he's back for the whole hour
tonight a true living legend of rock one
on one
Gene Simmons is rock and roll royalty
kiss have more gold certified records
than any other band on the planet
selling 75 million records in half a
century of touring and two months from
Rags to Riches team has turned his Beats
into a business Empire he's got the
longest tongue in rock and one of the
sharpest tons in politics they called
him Dr love the demon the God of Thunder
is quite possibly the world's smartest
ever rock star and tonight Gene Simmons
is uncensored
I've actually got a stinking cold and so
my first question was going to be when
you're a singer what do you do when you
get a stinking cold and you're on tour I
never claimed to be a singer what we do
is you just pile through it the kind of
music we do is certainly not operatic
and uh we don't pretend to be on X
Factor or any of that stuff you ever
lost your voice
no not in the way people think of it
it's uh because you just kind of plow
through it it's more uh you know sort of
gut kind of thing and I say that's a
jagger does the smart thing as well you
write songs in your vocal range without
very many high notes or very low so you
can you can do it even if your voice is
good have you ever had to cancel a show
for sickness you
kiss no you have you ever been
responsible for a show no
no in your entire career no never and
that's because
look this is a this is a blessing I
don't want to get too cornball about it
but by the way I look pretty good
the the idea that God or whomever is in
charge would give me a chance to lead
this kind of life it's just unbelievable
you know we're approaching 50 years uh
this year and this journey has been just
beyond anything so the least you could
do is show up on time
love and respect the fans and understand
that what you do isn't necessary food
shelter those are necessary things but
the people that stick their tongue out
and act like you know the the Court
Jester that's not necessary for Life as
we know it on the planet let me take you
back 50 years to your first show in the
UK which received the following review
from a gentleman called Tony Wilson who
went on to be of course a factory
records Legend this is what he said
about your first show when you first
popped up you guys
heavy metal perhaps it should be illegal
it's not all one way if we gave the
states the idea of music as physical
assault then they just repaid the
compliment with such bands as kiss who
had the same effect as using brillo pads
to get rid of acne can you also play
[Applause]
you project evil the question is I mean
is there any evil in you know what we're
not doing the show yet I don't want to
laugh let's redo the show
did you play football at school
[Music]
what do you feel looking at that
I if that was a new band I'd be
interested gee they look like yeah
they're having a lot of sighting
different exciting different and that
was the idea because we were such big
anglophiles uh American music to us was
just boring I mean I know America
created blues and rock and eventually
rap and all that but what the English
did this little island I know it
comprises whales and all the other
wonderful countries but this little
island gave the world the music that
stands the test of time the Beatles and
the kiss and we wanted to form a band
sort of like
The Beatles on steroids where everybody
in the band sang Everybody Was a star
every now of course we couldn't Shine
the Beatles shoes I'm not saying we're
anywhere near in that League nor would
we pretend to be but the idea the
template was that as opposed to the
stones where there's one guy in the
front and the guys are in the back and
what what an amazing life I still can't
believe it let me take you back to the
very start of this amazing life because
that in itself is truly extraordinary
and I think was the pivot really for
everything that followed and that's your
mother who was this remarkable woman who
at the age of 14 in World War II we've
got a picture of you with her there I
think you're about eight years old when
she was 14 she was taken into
concentration camps three in in the end
in World War II by the Nazis somehow
survived and will come to that
and then left at 19 having lost most
formative years of her life in this
appalling Holocaust
how much of an impact did that have not
just on her but on you
well look I uh
I was born in Israel I
and I didn't know anything about history
or life or anything it's just that I
knew that my mother was there
our father my father see even our I
didn't want to personalize it my father
left us when I was about six or seven
years of age unfortunately it's fairly
common fathers just pick up and leave
shameful as it is
and all I had was my mother and I was
the only child and she was my rock she
was my the foundation my moral compass
but I didn't know anything about my
mother she wouldn't talk about her
formative years hungry where she and my
father were born had never talked about
the concentration camps and as I got
older I tried to engage Mom I'm now a
sixth grade teacher in Spanish Harlem
and I know a little bit about the
history can you tell me she wouldn't do
it it was just too horrific and uh you
later discovered a lot of stuff about
what she'd been through from the
archives what did you find out about a
time in the concentration my mother at
14 13 14 had gone to frisor which is a
school for to learn how to do makeup and
hair and stuff like that and the way my
mother survived almost almost
to the t is what Sophie's Choice at
Meryl Streep movie is the common dance
wife and the concentration camp at
matthausen I found out
she wanted somebody who knew how to do
makeup and hair and stuff like that so
she brought some Jews in you know Jewish
girls anyone of you and they had a row
of young uh Jewish women and kanji sweat
and Deutsche I can speak a little German
I made sure I learned how to speak that
language
currency Spartan Deutsch
do Z and a few of the girls said uh you
know your country back in the business
enjoyed and they throw them out God
knows what happened to them my mother
who could get by in German actually
didn't raise her hands because she
understood the less I know I'm gonna
keep quiet and because my mother they
thought couldn't speak German she was
allowed to stay there and do the hair
for the commandant's wife and so on and
would sneak you know a piece of bread or
some old chicken the garbage pail and
that's how she survived astonishingly
and she and she told me when I finally
confronted her about that she told me
she didn't dare mention this to anybody
when she got back to the barracks
because she would be killed I would be
killed for the morsels of food as hard
it is to believe but and she lost a
large number of her family I have no
grandparents I didn't know anybody her
brother everybody and before she later
admitted my mother lived to be 94 years
of age
and always told me every day above
ground is a good day you know in
Hungarian
and i t i take that with me wherever I
go uh blessed and her mother my
grandmother who I've never met was being
led off to the gas Chambers with her
mother they took the oldest first and my
mother's mother would not let her mother
go to the gas chamber by herself she
willingly walked with her
and
in essence turned to my mother in
Hungarian and said live
uh survive and my name in in Hebrew is
Haim which means life
live you know it's the greatest gift
there is and uh and that's you know
despite everything despite the hardships
my mother's point of view about life and
everything was enjoy the little things
this glass of water and thank you for
this by the way I'll take a little bit
the water the thing you don't know what
you've got until and if it's gone
every day above ground is a good day you
better tattoo that on your soul right
now she also never and I've interviewed
a lot of Holocaust Survivors
she like them never had a trace of
self-pity no never played the victim no
never tugged on anybody's shirt sleeves
do you know what a horrible life I've
had no she refused to speak about it
Steven Spielberg who we've met a few
times reached out for the showa
foundation he wanted to interview the
survivors of the concentration camps and
wanted my mother uh to record her
experiences and she refused it was two
what she saw was beyond anything and of
course there are deniers out there
um unfortunately and but it's a lesson
for all of us and for those of you that
keep thinking that this is just the
Jewish experience very few people
understand that millions of gypsies
Christians undesirables
the homosexual Community there were
Millions were slaughtered there just
because they were unwanted you have a
very low tolerance of some of the modern
societal traits entitlement victimhood
you know all this kind of stuff is that
driven by what happened with your mother
of course if you don't have a sense of
history and where you came from and
stuff you take everything for granted
this entitlement thing is a disease of
modern pop culture wokism and so on our
kids Nick and Sophie are the most
wonderful human beings I know of they're
much better than Shannon and I Shannon's
right outside more ethical more moral
polite and all this kind of stuff I can
tell I can tend to push the button
sometimes like you can but for a fact
because we get off on it but they never
received a penny of an allowance this
idea of giving your kids money for not
doing anything is insane so they've
never done that in fact Shannon
drove the kids every day to school
without fail whether she was sick or not
for years and she volunteered to do the
lunch thing so that she can keep an eye
on her two children and Nick our son got
an award the only one they've ever given
for perfect attendance for the first
five years of going to school which oh
here I am talking about kids on the
Pierce Morgan show I'm sorry you're
allowed to I've got four kids I was
proud of them as you are as you as you
know of but go ahead let's take a short
break when I come back I want to talk to
you about the moment you move to America
you and your mum and that starts the
next phase of both your lives and it's
an extraordinary phase we'll talk about
that in a moment
we're dedicating the show tonight to
rock legend and kiss front man Gene
Simmons a gene you're up you're eight
years old your father's walked out on
you and your mother this remarkable
woman and she decides you're gonna try
your luck the two of you in America the
land of the free what are your first
memories of when you got to America I
remember a little before we came to
America my mother had two brothers who
were able to escape to America my mother
was
in in uh Hungary at the time that she
put into the camps and
we I didn't know where we were going I
didn't know what was going on and so my
mother took me to this thing and we
stood in the back of the line and I
didn't know it then but there was a man
sitting on a higher ledge with a desk
and people were lined up and my mother
in her younger years was just a very
very beautiful woman
and the man sitting there with what I
later Learned was the American flag is
uh
you know pointing to my mother in the
back of the line and says something in a
language I never heard of before and we
get to the front of the line and he
tries to communicate with her and he
bends over he's looking done and he says
uh uh do you speak I didn't know what
she was saying he was saying it in
English do you speak English and he
didn't speak Hebrew and he fumbled and
uh
Deutsch can you speak a little German
she says
you know so they start talking a little
bit in in German because he didn't speak
Hebrew
and what I later Learned was
um okay we've got your thing you're
going to America you're going to become
a citizen a few years down the line if
you behave and so on all I need you to
do is to swear Allegiance and some and
raise your hand
this uh sorry I get choked up when I
think about this but uh
my mother didn't
know uh what the guy meant so she did
the only thing that she saw she started
started to do this and uh
I didn't know what was going on and my
mother was you know kind of tearing up
and the man quickly got off
you know the pedestal came over to her
and I'll never forget this and God bless
him
uh he put his right hand above her left
hand uh pushed it down and later my
mother told me he told her you'll never
have to do that ever again wow and
and we came to America and I never saw
or dreamed anything like that the people
were big and everybody had cars and and
uh you know it's just uh and because we
came from dirt roads it was a new
country and there wasn't even an
infrastructure and we visited my aunt
Magda and she had a refrigerator she had
a refrigerator and she opened the
refrigerator it was full of food we
didn't have that you had a piece of
paper like the English fish and chips
you know where you stick it in a piece
of newspaper and stuff and you got your
allotment for the weekend I remember
looking at a jar of jam and in Hungarian
I speak Hungarian as well
and asking my aunt Magda in Hungarian
she too had been in the camps what is
this and she goes you know she gave me a
spoon and opened the thing and she
thought I was going to get a taste and
as soon as I tasted it I started eating
it because I'd never tasted anything
like that and both my mother and my aunt
were were laughing their heads off they
I'd never saw television I never saw
people flying through the air with capes
and I never saw anything I'm still
Marvel at this amazing country yes it
has its blisters it's racism it's all
kinds of bad things with it but
I think
clearly the UK and so on to start up
started with guy Fox before he tried to
blow up everything and I know but the
history of democracy is the only hope we
have on this planet
you're a perfect example you and your
mother of America taking in pretty much
anyone and giving them the chance of a
different better life which has always
been at its core what the United States
of America is about ideally it's a lot
messier than that I do think that there
is and this always gets me into heart
trouble even though I'm a big proponent
of giving people a chance the world is a
very sad place there's a lot of things
but you've got to have some kind of
order otherwise it's chaos because the
good
comes in along with the bad so I believe
in legal immigration just slow it down a
little bit let people at least know your
names where you are social security
number and so on so you can keep track
of what's going on that goes for all the
countries that take in you know sad sad
stories about immigrants legal
immigration is
the right way to do it you several
things happen to you one you get bullied
as a kid when you get to America and
eventually you fight back tell me about
that moment
I uh I had never been in a fight in in
Israel I was sort of bigger than ever
but I'd never been in a fight I didn't
pick on anybody you know Live and Let
Live thing
and I remember
um
being somebody was starting to pick on
me and
I don't remember what happened but it
was a snap it was this kind of uh uh
Jekyll hunt thing that had happened
right along and I didn't know about head
butting or anything but I just hurled my
body at this guy who was two or three
years older than I am and as it happened
my forehead uh hit his face and he went
down like uh an alternate I didn't know
what happened it hurt me I was just
holding my head up and
I thought I was going to be in trouble
with my mother and when I told her about
it
she was proud you know because for the
longest time our people have been you
know a simulationist and you just kind
of don't cause troubles don't fight back
it didn't work out well in World War II
you hate bullies don't you because I
won't stand for it by the way verbal
bullies as well
if you uh if you pick on people
I'm at the front line trying to stop
that because there but for the grace of
God if you allow a group of people or
somebody to be bullied your next pill
everybody everybody is part of a segment
of life and or religion or culture and
so on that that can be picked on and is
picked on so I won't stand for so you
have this moment you fight back you feel
good about yourself for doing that your
mother feels good about you then you see
a little later you see the Beatles on
The Ed Sullivan Show and a light bulb
goes off again and you're thinking not
that you want to be exactly like them
because they're a unique I wish you
wanted you wanted that
I must have been 13 or 14 years of age
maybe 13 and think 1964.
and I'd always worked after school and
it was even on Sundays and it was Sunday
in New York and there was the Ed
Sullivan Show where half the population
of the entire country in America at that
time was 150 million population now it's
330 something million
75 million people watch that show yeah
and the Beatles come out what do you
think you've lost your love you know all
this sound that I never heard before and
I was mesmerized and I thought to myself
gee they look silly in a you know what's
this and they're smaller they're smaller
and slight and they looked you know a
little feminine to uh you know guys
because we're used to you know bigger
guys and my mother comes in and
basically verbalizes the same thing oh
look how silly they look and at that
moment I thought oh they're cool that's
when I started paying attention the
girls were screaming and these guys were
having a good time and I said Gee that's
a good job wish I could do that and when
I first tried to do that I couldn't do
that but I will tell you time to admit
it for a few years
I was 13 until I was about 15 years ago
at 12 o'clock now I did but if I didn't
actually I tried to convince everybody
oh I'm not from here because no do you
know the beautiful of course yes
[Laughter]
did you ever beat the Beatles
um Ringo he's sent me a birthday
greeting at uh Paul my partner obviously
is Matt Sir Paul and just the most
lovely people of all time you wanna you
wanna see somebody with Grace class
after Beetle Mania and stuff you sit
talk with Ringo or Paul and you see
that's the way you do it that should be
the mark of how to be gracious I
completely agree oh I think he's an
absolute God in that sense uh
informed kiss I'm not going to go over
the whole history again except to say
that there's a moment
when it all kicks off and you become
this huge band and you're living the
dream that you have when you watch The
Beatles on the O'Sullivan show and you
go to your mother and you have a check
for a million dollars it wasn't a
million how much was it
say it eight eight million eight million
dollars and you show her that check yeah
and how does she respond she didn't
understand it my mother never went to uh
proper school or anything and in
Hungarian you know she just saw the
zeros and stuff and
she literally didn't understand in fact
she used to ask me all the time who pays
you when when do you go to work where do
you go to works because she understood
you go to work at a certain time
somebody pays you I said you know the
people pay me anyway when I showed her
the check I wasn't giving her I said
look look mom look at this money she
didn't understand wonderful wonderful
now what are you going to do
literally because she was worried that
you may just stop working or well I
don't know it was always yesterday it
didn't matter yes and that's a profound
point of view about life which is
there's nothing you can do about
yesterday my mother bless her
was in a concentration camp and yet
never referenced that in her dealings
with people today which is incredible
because something you can do about today
and if you can fix today you can make
tomorrow better and my mother was the
funniest person I ever met how is the
orchestra that's how she called yeah
I want to talk about kiss not just the
band but the brand because almost
uniquely you turned kiss into this money
making machine globally as a brand as
much as a band as we see there with your
phone cover so back with Gene Simmons
after break well welcome back to my
special with Gene Simmons
if you could only
perform live on stage
again throughout your life or have sex
with all the women you had sex with
leave it leave it but you couldn't do
both which one would you go for
the women or the live performing
well I'm married now obviously Pierce
obviously and my lovely wife is right
outside I know and I'm going to ask her
the same question oh my God uh
well look uh doing what I do wearing
more makeup and higher heels than any
female you ever met literally
has been just unbelievable but sex is
pretty good too so which one why do you
have to pick well you've got to choose
it's a binary question
on stage because I knew you'd say that
because you also get paid bam when you
certainly get paid so from 76 to 79 it's
become the biggest band in the world you
still hold the record the most gold
albums money back you sort of a hundred
million records worldwide you've told
the world dozens of times and now it's
coming to an end the touring how do you
feel about that how do you really feel
about that I really feel proud uh the
best part was when I ran into my buddy
Paul Stanley who
uh we continue to have this astonishing
relationship and I've always been so sad
when Leonard McCartney and Jagger and
Richard started yes you know backbiting
I mean even Kane and Abel didn't get
along so well
uh it was always so sad to me and but
Paul and I have this resilient sort of
the brother I never had uh kind of a
thing and we don't agree on very much at
all but there's an abiding uh admiration
respect for
the talent that He has that I will never
have and hopefully the piece of the
puzzle that I bring to it that he
doesn't know that no question so that
one and one you have an amazing
chemistry it it works one and one is
three you don't know everything I don't
and when you meet somebody that's a you
know kindred spirit you you can run and
be bigger than you ever were and at any
rate to cut to the chase
all good things have to come to an end
and you have to have the self-respect
and pride that's a big word
and the love of the fans to know when
the hell it's time to get off that stage
do you see a lot of bands who just oh of
course who go on too long look at that
that wasn't so long ago I don't remember
where that was this is in your farewell
tour yeah yes it is but all the shows
are like that just right insane but you
see other bands go on too long is that
they go too long yeah and it's tough to
give it up you know this kind of AD
right and it's god-like you know I would
love this and uh but but at any rate
when you still look good when you still
have the physicality it takes to do that
get off the stage by the way it goes for
boxers too
um
Muhammad Ali Mike Tyson who's a friend
and so on these These are the greats of
all time and you've got you've got to
know when it's time to go they'll know
when to leave the party right I think
Sinatra said you must yeah so I got an
insight into your marketing genius when
we both appeared on Celebrity Apprentice
back in 2008 with Donald Trump obviously
was the host but what I remember most
was my first insane to you as a
businessman was we were told to do a hot
dog challenge we literally had to sell
hot dogs from a stand in Midtown
Manhattan actually outside the fox now
just a second Trump did not mention a
stand all he said was selling that's
true that's true which is why I'm going
to come to you but a genius so we were
deliberating as a group whether to
charge ten dollars or a hundred dollars
for our dogs
you picked your phone up and called a
mate and said will he give me five
thousand dollars for a hot dog ten was
it and he said okay and he said to me
I'll never forget this you said it's not
the vacuum cleaner that gets sold it's
the way the salesman sells the cleaner
and I've remembered that ever since yeah
it's true because that's really the
essence of where marketing takes a
business and explodes it right well if
you can if you can assess and everything
is about an assessment you know where
you go what road to take and so on if
you understand that it's not how many
units you sell but how much money you
make then it isn't always about units
sold it's about you know I'd rather sell
one Rolls-Royce than 20 Volkswagen right
right so it's not how many units it's
how much money can I make and the rules
were very clear I was listening sell hot
dogs didn't say where or when or all
that stuff and your uh you can't call
people you're in business with so I just
called people I knew and I said this is
for charity I'm not going to get any of
the money give me ten thousand I made a
few of those calls in the very first
phone call we beat the female we did
because it was with one call with one
dog because actually you understood how
to play the game which was brilliant you
also hold on but who won well I won
obviously
but you know how I won because I watched
what you did I listened to what you said
and I thought yes and I then hit my
Rolodex and I then got a lot of other
people who came to help me in the same
way particularly in the final actually
was very interesting
um but you also took this obviously and
had done before then to the Rock
business in a way I don't think anyone's
ever done that as well as you guys did
with this well we make a living rob you
made an incredible franchise out of Kiss
where you have I think over 5 000 lines
of merchandise I just want to stop here
for a second because self-aggrandizement
and other big words like gymnasium I
enjoy hearing nice things said about me
but it's never just about you Paul's my
partner no no from the beginning you
have the right you have to surround
yourself with the right people who
understand it so you can go forth
together but thank you for the kind
words five thousand different pieces of
mud should I do the joke we literally
uh no joke intended we literally have
everything from Kiss condoms to kiss
caskets we'll get you coming and we'll
get you going there is a kiss toilet
seat oh yeah we've got a hair
you know the phrase sit down so well I
said on my face
so right there
of course these are semantics but we've
got a kiss lunchbox oh sure there are
many jokes of course
well I think the point about it is you
just understood how to sell the man the
business you guys I'm not just in the
band I'm a fan of the band and I
remember uh when the Beatles first came
out there were a lot of beetle things
Beetle this Beetle that but then that
they never made the money they didn't
understand uh
you know the the marketplace and so on
because it was all brand new but we
wanted to be Disney without the overhead
right you could make an awful lot of
money if you understand everything by
the way I'm the only person on the
planet that owns the pound sign it's
trademarked right yeah I'll show it to
you including the euro because countries
are smart but not that smart they create
trademark laws but never trademark the
word England
public domain why well I have to
trademarked that so I do own well you've
also got one of these which is a kiss
coffin casket yeah have you ordered one
of these for the when the time comes oh
no I think I'll
splatter I mean a shot or whatever it is
you know the dust particles and so on
but they also double and the bars have
them because they're moisture proof so
you put ice in it and people reach in
and have cold drinks out of it true how
much money have you made from Kiss oh
come on you that's the first question I
was going to ask you Pierce Morgan how
much money does it take justice
give me a number that's going to horrify
me no that's that's not fair I've read
that you're worth 400 million dollars
really yeah
hahaha
no it's true you're very kind I'll pull
down
up or down what from 400. I I always
want to go up
but I tell you what here's a point for
all you folks out there I'm kind of a
big deal you go to your uh cell phone
and you type in into Google and smuggle
Gene Simmons gum
uh when I was singing the National
Anthem here for the NFL football team I
was chewing gum the day before and doing
soccer am the promotion thing and I was
chewing gum and they said Mr Simmons
please take out your gum and I because
I'm a wise guy I said eBay the next day
they put it on eBay how much Pierce
Morgan how much does he go for I asked
you first I let me guess five thousand
pounds would you like a tip
uh if I went to the Empire State
Building and pointed up how much would
that number be how much was it got
247 thousand dollars well for a piece of
guns I chewed by you Gene Simmons
that's true
you can Google and smuggle it talking of
Google what do you make of the tech
World we're now in what do you make of
Elon Musk and artificial intelligence
and all these I'm a big fan uh and like
like all people they're the ones that uh
change history and make life better on
Earth was uh Thomas Edison uh who
literally changed Life as we know it a
good guy or a bad guy probably a
combination of both actually he was and
Ford the guy that created the assembly
line was actually a big anti-semite and
probably didn't uh
like many quote foreigners but they're
the the single people the the forward
thinkers the futurists change Life as We
Know It Elon Musk is undeniable he tried
for years to get car companies to go
away from diesel fuel and you know gas
and so on they wouldn't let so he did it
himself it's always the individual not
the corporate entity because you can
move you can move fast you don't have to
make decisions by committee I'm a big
fan Twitter's going to be fine yeah I
totally agree with you are you are you
excited or are you worried about
artificial intelligence particularly
about the music business I am concerned
music business aside I am concerned
about the lack of legislation when you
enter a new let's say a new planet
you're about to land on new well clearly
there's opportunity there there are
minerals and things and so uh you know
all kinds of opportunities without rules
of the game it's like Spain playing
sports without rules who's going to do
what you need some rules that are you
know kind and beneficial to mankind
women kind trans kind All Kinds of Kinds
okay does that cover everybody and so
probably not well they're always going
to be nuance and you have to respect all
that subject aside the problem with AI
is not AI is here whether you like it or
not so let's look at it smartly and
let's pass legislation AI creates a song
using my voice or what sounds like my
voice with a new song and it sounds just
like me and it definitely sounds like
that kind of a thing so when you're
buying it who owns the copyright and the
publishing if AI did them so is it me
because it sounds like me you could
swear it was me so these are and if it
is you do you then care if if AI does
that we can make a deal
of course of course uh we're talking
you're making a deal let's come back
after the break with the best deal I
think you've made in your life which is
persuading your wife Shannon not just to
marry you but to stay with you that's
after the break welcome back to people
when I said so we've been joined Now by
my special guest wife Shannon the boss
finally we have you uh last tweet we
have you right where I want Gene to be
let me ask you straight off the top yeah
he when you met him was one of the
biggest rock stars in the world yeah I
didn't know that but yes would it
mattered if he was a plumber oh yeah
I have to I wouldn't have dated him I I
asked her Shannon if I didn't make a
good living and I'm going to try not to
exaggerate if I did make a good living
would you be with me and she said see ya
but you must have known when you met him
I guess his reputation I did not um but
by the way no I I what did you mean I
grew up listening
at the Playboy Mansion really
um it was a party he came in with two uh
I know girls and um someone suggested a
producer friend of mine that I go over
and meet him my sisters like come on
come on let's go meet him I said I don't
know who that is it looks kind of a
little smarmy to me and uh so I went
over to meet him and you know we got to
talking and we had a lot in common
actually
um but the next day since there's no
cell phones or Internet and so on uh we
ran down to Tower Records to look him up
to make sure it was real because I
didn't believe the word he said I saw an
entire section yeah it was kiss this and
yeah when you realized he was never
really listened to that music before it
was I was Motown girl she just loves Tom
Jones that's it yeah yeah what was it
that made you fall in love with him
um it is smart
and um
that's it
smart and Rich
and he's very romantic actually and um
did you make him cry yet he cried yeah
emotional yeah yeah I like that I was
surprised yeah is that really bad
boyfriend but uh very good husband well
that's interesting it almost is like
your relationship is two halves yeah up
to up to later it took 28 years for him
to grow up right yeah so but I waited oh
my God why did you wait many would have
gone I know I know and a lot of people
were like once your husband cheats on
you once they ditch and uh what about
when it's 5 000 times there's more what
there's more to him than that yeah he's
a bit of this he said that there's two
two Gene Simmons believe me I've heard
it huh yeah and you believe that yeah
sure oh yeah but I mean it's hard when
you're I now that I have a young man as
a child I know that you know when a girl
comes to your door and wearing a
raincoat with nothing under it and you
don't just go bye-bye
so uh I understand that it happened and
meant almost nothing
I don't know that he remembers anybody's
name but
um
to have a relationship would have
bothered me more than to have a physical
yes interaction I've got a picture of
you on your wedding day ah this took a
long time uh Gene if you did persuade
Shannon to get down there what do you
what do you both remember that day I
have to tell you that I never wanted to
get married and I never had kids at
least at least uh consciously I didn't
want to become my father my father uh
but he didn't know he was his father
because his father was a philanderer and
that's why his mother left him and and
so like but he wasn't but he was a
philanderer and um he came by it
honestly and um uh but you can't I mean
I don't know how how can you blame a
musician well obviously just knocking on
your door and they're naked when you
open it up I just you say what do you
say I didn't want to have kids because I
didn't want
kids feeling what I felt the world ended
I felt like what it I felt guilty what
did I do wrong that made my father get
up and leave without explaining anything
so
and yet
am I doing okay she's not letting you
get away with a thing here no no you're
not getting off the hook at this one
what am I doing well let me ask you a
different question okay Jim what would
you say to your son for example or your
daughter if they ask you about these
stories where you've given interviews
we've talked about having thousands of
groupies what do you say to your kids if
they ask those questions
at some point you gotta grow up I don't
know what to say except that uh there's
no look at that he said that's not he
said it was fun but it's over now
wow do you believe it is John I didn't
oh elf definitely
I I cut off my schmeckle and I will
formalda or she will put another
formalda put it on a pickle jar a pickle
jar
broadly though made you happier than not
absolutely yeah yeah and when you say
it's romantic how does that manifest
itself what's the most romantic thing
he's done for you oh my gosh I gave you
some cash yesterday
you know what he really does just give
me wands of cash yeah
yeah did you sell any guitars today
[Applause]
and when she gets the watch it goes like
this Gene what is what is true love
romantic the part though he did do the
the flower petals really yeah yeah yeah
yeah so what does true love mean to
Eugene because obviously you found it
with Shannon but what what does it mean
fully I
never confronted myself about that and
barely said I love you to my mother yeah
shockingly shamefully I I don't I was
always alone he thought it was a
weakness have you said it to Shannon yes
yes it happened much later
it happened much later I was afraid of
English of being weak not and not
I I never opened myself up to that you
know I always
it's hard you know the uh knight in
shining armor thing at least you have
protection around you and I never wanted
to be hurt ever again like now she's
about to say well sure no I uh what can
I say there's no school for life and
there's no school that says okay this is
what marriage is this is what a
relationship we're both learning as we
went along
when I met him too right what have you
really learned about yourself Gene
I've learned that I'm not so bad after
all
[Laughter]
Shannon would you agree I would I would
yeah I would say it's not so bad after
all
yeah I really thought I was gonna
if it was gonna be I look I'd been in
only two other relationships of any kind
never wanted sort of you weren't
faithful to them either
well one was Cher famously and Diana and
Donna Ross who was who you were with
before you mentioned philandering at the
same time he was yeah sure right with me
you wanna you wanna hear crazy stories
yes absolutely it was cut to the chase
so I and she's a wonderful lady there's
nothing bad to say about it sure so
Diana what did you say true and who are
we talking about yeah
and we had a just great times lovely
little and uh so I met Shannon at the
Playboy Mansion where there are hundreds
of girls or at least two or three
hundred barely wearing anything and the
guys had a pajama party pajamas you
didn't wear pajamas it was all well I
didn't sleep at all pushed together
and the guy I wore a pair of pajamas
that were too small so small that you
could guess my religion
see what I just did there
and she took me by the hand downstairs
pressed a button like a James Bond thing
with a book case opened up and she took
me downstairs and there's like a pool
thing and shut the door behind The Wine
Cellar
yeah
you know as is my won't I would have
normally
but I did I was I became fascinated in
the person uh came from a big family
from Newfoundland and so on we started
talking about family strange of all
things you know she's barely wearing
anything me too I mean literally and so
I decided I've got to find out more
about this I'm skipping because you've
only got an hour wait why didn't you
kiss me that night
I don't know I was uh see it's all
coming out now why didn't he Jean we
were talking
the other stuff stopped you know we have
we have blood but not enough for two
heads you know women Shannon I mean
you've got to admit I mean go share
Diana Ross mate you yeah it's not bad
but that's not fair well but older women
with children than me oh stop it that's
fine okay so I'm going to finish my
story quickly so that was a young and
single I called Diana and I said look I
just want you to know before you read it
in Paparazzi and schmaparazzi I'm seeing
this girl
and I'm gonna take time and find out
what's going on because I'm completely
unprepared for this
and you know she wasn't happy with a few
weeks later we're staying at the
libertage hotel I remember specifically
on Burton boy in L.A and uh Mr Simmons
you've got a phone call from a woman
claiming to be Diana Ross no no put it
through it
and we and we talked you know very no
histrionics nothing are you still seeing
this girl yeah is she six feet tall
blonde yeah well she's sort of my
sister-in-law
because what yeah unbeknownst to me
Shannon my sister had a lot of brother
oh my God
Diana's brother it didn't last long but
it didn't happen so you kept it in the
family I yeah like if you were to try to
make it up you couldn't make it yeah
Gene it's been brilliant I'm so glad we
did a much bigger interview great to
have you adding some Stardust at the end
uh thank you both very much indeed your
time I really appreciate it thank you
well that's it for me whatever up to I
think just keep it like Gene Sims Keep
It Uncensored good night